j'ai fait mes super women bonsoir
bonsoir
illimité
seulement peut sembler utopique
mais je veux vous rassurer que ce soit
lors que vous franchirez le seuil de
cette forte vous aurez un accès illimité
à internet
ce soir lorsque vous il est d'avoir deux
restaurants favoris il vous suffira
juste de donner mon nom et vous aurez un
accès illimité au menu de votre choix
et j'espère enfin que ce soit lorsque
vous franchissez le seuil de cette porte
ce que nous aurons partager avec vous
permettra de coin de conscience et de
vous rappeler chaque jour de votre vie
de votre potentiel illimité
mesdames et messieurs j'ai envie de vous
demander au jour d'aujourd'hui
est ce que vous vivez la vie de beaux
rêves
voilà vous vous contentez juste de rêver
de votre vie parkin différence entre
vivre la vie de ses rêves et rêver et sa
vie ce soir j'ai le même rêve ça fond et
on savait si aujourd'hui encore pour le
moment vous ne vivez pas la vie de vrai
et comme vous ne rêvait que de votre vie
c'est normal parce que des études ont
prouvé que la réalité
80% de la population mondiale manque de
confiance en elle ce qui fait qu'elle
n'est pas en mesure de hausser ce qu'il
empêche de réaliser ses rêves
c'est pourquoi ce soir j'ai choisi et
j'ai décidé de vous parler de confiance
en soi parce que pour moi la confiance
en soi c'est la clé du succès la
confiance en soi ce qui vous permet pas
d'atteindre objectif que réaliser chacun
de vos rêves
mesdames et messieurs vous savez si
aujourd'hui encore vous n'avez tout le
monde a confiance en vous ses serres il
y à des formations qui existent
vous pouvez développer votre confiance
en vous mais comme le dit couramment il
est beaucoup plus facile de les dresser
du bois vert que du bois sic voici
pourquoi pour moi il est important qu en
tant que parent en tant que futurs
parents nous soyons en mesure
d'accompagner nos enfants que dès le bas
âge nous leur donnions le nécessaire
vous qu'il puisse avoir confiance en eux
et le succès qu'ils ont envie mais le
succès de vous avez envie qu'il soit
avant de poursuivre j'aimerais me
représenter et vous raconter une petite
histoire
je suis mes arrêts matile à il a tout
zerbo zerbo qui veut dire dit celui qui
montre le chemin on est d'accord que
pour montrer le chemin aux autres il
faut un tant soit peu soi-même connaître
le chemin sur lequel on va il faut
savoir où est ce qu'on sera et j'ai eu
des parents j'ai eu une famille
formidable qui m'a montré le chemin qui
m'a accompagné sur le chemin ça commence
en 2006
je n'ai peut-être pas l'air mais en
réalité je suis une personne timide pour
ne pas dire plenty
déservi leur temps le mineur j'arrivais
au collège le premier jour de classe
c'était l'élection de la déléguée de la
classe
j'étais la plus jeune j'étais leur plus
petit la plume s et j'étais raciste tout
de même à la première table
lorsqu'on a une année qui souhaitait
prendre les rênes de cette place
du 22 mai à l'être c'est quand j'ai osé
lever mon petit doigt tout frêle et je
me suis présenté
pourquoi malgré que je sois timmy qu'est
ce qui va pousser à lever le petit doigt
tout frais à les allaiter ce matin là
lorsque mon père m'amenait à l'école il
m'a demandé
at-il qu'elle est en réalité dans
l'objectif pour cette année est si tu
t'es seuil est à prendre de nouvelles
responsabilités
et si tu tu essayais à l'idée est tamara
parce qu'en réalité je sais je suis
confiant que china les capacités je sais
que tu es capable
des délégués de cette claque je sais que
tu peux l'idée les autres voici là une
phrase qui a résonné dans ma tête voici
là une fois ce qui m'a motivée et qui
m'a inspiré a levé mon petit doigt pelle
pour au final fini délégués de classe en
classe de sixième
merci au fur et à mesure que je demande
10 est japonaise des conflits au fur et
à mesure que je grandissais je
découvrais les passions au fur et à
mesure que je disais je sentais la vie
et le besoin d'affirmer qu'ils gt
gt une étudiante
il élève un ciel et scientifique et
voici comme fleur de pommier on décide
de lancer un concours de poésie oui vous
n'avez lèvres de ces scientifiques c'est
normal que des camarades se moquent deux
fois plutôt que de chercher à participer
à des concours de mathématiques de
physique chimie tu t'intéresses aux
lèves tu t'intéresses à la pause
pourquoi est ce que tu penses en réalité
que tu t'expliques aussi bien que ses
élèves de la série littéraire qui vont
participer également à ce concours tu
n'as aucune chance
mais là encore une fois de plus je me
suis rappelé d'une de ces journées vous
savez nous par africains généralement il
nous a tellement qu'il ordonne de talent
et 12 collection art et hameaux
alors à jouer avec mon père mais
copieusement mais avec toute son
affection corriger il m'a demandé est ce
que tu sais pourquoi aujourd'hui tu as
doit cette collection
parce qu'en réalité
ce français de tu viens de me parler
n'est pas un français pourraient se fera
c'est que tu viens de me parler et la
jument and de sa vie n'est pas pratique
et d'expression ce français que tu viens
de me parler mathilde aujourd'hui tu me
laisses à dehors parce que en réalité
j'ai capable de s'exprimer dans un
langage sous 2 tu as le vert tu as les
capacités nec qui tu veux et tu es en
mesure de s'exprimer comme une grande
personne
alors j'ai participé à ce concours de
poésie et je ne dirais pas a
miraculeusement mais j'ai remporté le
premier prix
parmi tous mes camarades de la série
littéraire
j'ai envie de vous poser une question
qu'est ce que je dit charge ou à vos
enfants
comment est ce que voulait sa compagne
et qu'en réalité
voulais l'aider à développer ce
potentiel qui gagnent
houara vous parle du pied à refermer et
à faire en sorte que ce potentiel ne
s'exprime pas
j'ai envie de vous dire que
tous et tout autant que le sommes nous
pouvons être ce que nous voulons nous
pouvons réaliser
ce que nous avons envie de réaliser et
de ça il nous manque parfois juste un
peu de confiance en
chef alors si
vous tenez à boire aux enfants eux parce
que c'est le souhait de chaque parent
dès aujourd'hui commencer à les
accompagner commencé à les visiter
commencé à faire en sorte que notre
confiance n'est ce mic lundi commençait
à faire en sorte qu'il se sente femme
aux yeux parce que les premiers
supporteurs de chaque individu sont
d'abord leur part les membres de leur
famille et ceux qui côtoient le plus
fréquemment
je suis matière beau mais c'est
généraliste de formation
je suis également coach formatrice
bahia
malgré que je sois une série
scientifique
j'ai la chance de remporter le
championnat international de débat
francophone à beyrouth en 2019
j'ai eu la chance de remporter le
concours d'éloquence de l'université
paris 1 panthéon sorbonne en 2019 j'ai
eu la chance d'être la famille des de
l'équipe qui a remporté la coupe à
l'africain de débarrer d'art oratoire
organisée par les premières dames de
l'umoa en 2019 si je suis ce que je suis
aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas uniquement parce que j'ai
ce n'est pas uniquement votre potentiel
illimité qui résident en moi mais parce
que chez lui des personnes g8 départ qui
m'ont accompagné et que je parle
d'environnement je pense à ses amis là
qui ont toujours été là pour moi parce
que lorsque je commençais nouvellement
les images oratoire c'est ce qu'il me
disait oui mathilde dit avec nous parce
que tu as le potentiel tu sait
convaincre gillard et nous parce que tu
seras un maillon fort de cette équipe et
je pense à dominique ou là ou à jonathan
grave ou afin justement à marie paule
aléa
chapeau
cherchons pas
en réalité nos enfants deviennent ce
qu'on l'a prévu qu'ils soient nos
enfants devient le succès qu'on a
inculqué en jeu dès le bas âge
chers parents
j'ai envie que à partir d'aujourd'hui
chaque mot comme tuléar enfants chaque
phrase que vous leur direz puisaye une
source de motivation
mais ce n'est qu'une source qui leur
permet pas de grandi près le rat est le
rocher sur lequel ils pourront s'appuyer
à tout moment et dans chaque situation
de leur vie
la confiance au soir
c'est
ce monsieur
qui est il en a été chassée de l'école
parce que pour les titres 10 il m'arrive
pas les capacités intellectuelles
nécessaires
pour poursuivre les études
alors l'établissement et une led qu'on a
donné un enfant pour sa mère
lorsqu'il avait appris la lettre elle a
juste lu
votre enfant est un génie
ses capacités intellectuelles sont
tellement immense que notre école ne
veut pas le garder
depuis ce jour commun et y sol a pris
confiance en lui ce monsieur qui à la
base aux yeux du commun des mortels
pouvait ressembler à tanner grâce
uniquement à la phrase de sa mère grâce
uniquement à tout ce qu'il a pu avoir de
sa famille de ses parents ont permis
qu'il soit ce scientifique de renom
le succès de nos enfants dépend d'eux je
vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]